a couple of videos ago I made the
statement that the rank the rank of a
matrix a is equal to the rank of its
transpose and I made a bit of a hand
wavy argument it was at the end of the
video and I was tired it was actually
the end of the day and I thought it was
it'd be worthwhile to I maybe flush this
out a little bit because it's an
important take away it'll help us
improve understand everything we've
learned a little bit better so let's
just understand what the actually I want
to start with the rank of a transpose
the rank of a transpose the rank the
rank of a transpose is equal to the
dimension of the column space of a
transpose that's the definition of the
rank and what is it the dimension of the
column space of a transpose is the
number of basis vectors basis vectors
for the column space of a transpose
that's what dimension is for any
subspace you figure out how many basis
vectors you need in that subspace and
you count them and that's your dimension
so it's the number of basis vectors for
the column space of a transpose which is
of course the same thing this thing
we've seen multiple times is the same
thing as the row space of a row space of
a right the columns of a transpose are
the same thing as the rows of a is
because you switch the rows and the
columns now how can we figure out the
number of basis vectors we need for the
column space of a transpose or the row
space of a so let's just think about
what the column space of a transpose is
telling us so it's equivalent to so
let's say let me draw a like this let me
draw a of some matrix a let's say it's
an M by n matrix and let me just write
it as a bunch of row vectors I could
also write it as a bunch of column
vectors but right now let's just stick
to the row vectors so we'd have row 1
then the transpose of column vectors we
can just write that's Row 1 and we're
going to have Row 2 and I have Row 2 and
we're going to go all the way down to
row M right it's an M by n matrix each
of these vectors are members of RN
because they're going to have n entries
in them because we have end
so that's what a is going to look like a
is going to look like that and then a
transpose a transpose all of these rows
are going to become columns a transpose
is going to look like this r1 r2
all the way to RM and this is of course
going to be an N by M matrix you swap
these out so all these rows are going to
be columns right and obviously the
column space or maybe not so obviously
the column space of a transpose the
column space of a transpose is equal to
the span the span of r1 r2
all the way to RM right it's equal to
the span of these things or you could
equivalently call it it's equal to the
span of the rows of a that's why it's
called so called the row space so this
is equal to the span of the rows rows of
a these two things are equivalent now
these are the span that means this is
some subspace it's all of the linear
combinations of these columns or all the
linear combinations of these rows if we
want the basis for it we want to find a
minimum set of linearly independent
vectors that we could use to construct
any of these columns or that we could
use to construct any of these rows right
here now what happens when we put a into
reduced row echelon form so let's just
we do a bunch of row operations row
operations to put it into reduced row
echelon form right you do a bunch of row
operations and you eventually you'll get
something like this you'll get the
reduced row echelon form of a the
reduced row echelon form of a is going
to look something like this you're going
to have some pivot rows some rows that
have pivot entries let's say that's one
of them let's say the second let's say
that's one of them this will all have
zeros all the way down this one will
have zeros your pivot entry has to be
the only nonzero entry in its column and
everything to the left of it also has to
be 0 let's say that this one isn't these
are some nonzero values these are 0 so
we have another pivot entry over here
everything else is 0 and let's say
everything else
our non-pivot entries so you come here
and you add a certain number of pivot
rows or a certain number of pivot
entries right and you got there by
performing linear row operations on
these guys so those linear row
operations you know I take three times
Row 2 and I add it to Row 1 and I write
you know then that's going to become my
new Row 2 and you keep doing that and
you get these things here so these
things here are linear combinations of
those guys or another way to do it you
could reverse those row operations I
could start with these guys right here
and I could just as easily perform the
reverse row operations you know you can
any linear operation you can perform the
reverse of it we've seen that multiple
times you could perform row operations
you could perform row operations with
these guys to get all of these guys or
another way to view it is these vectors
here these row vectors right here they
span all of these all of these or all of
these row vectors can be represented as
linear combinations of your pivot rows
right here obviously you're going to
have your non pivot rows are going to be
all zeros are going to be all zeros and
those are useless
those are useless but your pivot rows if
you take linear combinations of them you
can clearly put you can clearly kind of
do reverse row echelon form and get back
to your matrix so all of these guys can
be represented as linear combinations of
them and all of these pivot entries are
by definition our our Bibles almost by
definition they're linearly independent
right because I've got a one here no one
else has a one there so no one else can
be so this guy can definitely not be
represented as a linear combination of
the other guy so why am I going through
this whole exercise well we started off
saying we wanted a basis we wanted a
basis for the row space we wanted some
minimum set of linearly independent
vectors that spans everything that these
guys can span well if all of these guys
can be represented as linear
combinations of these row vectors in
reduced row echelon form or these pivot
rows in reduced in reduced row echelon
form and these guys are all linearly
independent then they are a reasonable
basis so these pivot rows right here
that's one of them this is the second
one this is the third one maybe they're
the only three this is just my
particular example that would be a
suitable basis for the row space so let
me write this down
the pivot rows pivot rows in reduced
row-echelon form of a are a basis are a
basis for the row space row space of a
and the row space of a is the same thing
you know or the column space of a
transpose row space of a is the same
thing as a column space of a transpose
we've seen that multiple times now so if
we want to know the dimension of your
column space where you just count the
number of pivot rows you have so you
just count the number of pivot rows so
the dimension of your row space which is
the same thing as a column space of a
transpose is going to be the number of
pivot rows you have in reduced row
echelon form or even simpler the number
of pivot entries you have because every
pivot entry as a pivot row so we can say
we can write that the rank the rank of a
transpose is equal to the number of
pivot entries pivot entries in reduced
row echelon form of a right because
every pivot entry corresponds to a pivot
row those pivot rows are a suitable
basis I'll compete for the entire row
space because every row can be read with
a linear combination of these guys and
since that all of these can be then
anything that these guys can construct
these guys can construct fair enough now
what is the rank of a this is the rank
of a transpose that we've been dealing
with so far the rank of a the rank the
rank of a is equal to the dimension the
dimension of the column space of a or
you could say it's the number of vectors
in the basis for the column space of a
so if we take that same that same matrix
a that we used above and we instead we
write it as a bunch of column vectors so
c1 c2 all the way to CN we have end
columns right there the column space is
essentially the subspace that's spanned
by all of these characters right here
right spanned by each of these column
vectors so the column space of a is
equal to the span of c1 c2 all the way
to CN that's the definition of it but we
want to know the number of basis vectors
and we've seen before we've done this
multiple times the basis vectors or a
suitable basis vectors could be if you
put this into reduced row echelon form
and you have some pivot entries and
their corresponding pivot columns so
some pivot entries with their
corresponding pivot columns just like
that maybe that's like that and then
maybe this one isn't one and then this
one is so you have a certain number of
pivot columns you have a certain number
of pivot columns let me do them in
another color right here when you put a
into reduced row echelon form we learned
that the basis vectors or the basis
columns that form a basis for your
column space are the columns that
correspond to the pivot columns so this
the first column here is a pivot column
so this guy could be a basis vector the
second column is so this guy could be a
pivot vector and maybe the fourth one
right here so this guy could be a pivot
vector so in general you just say hey
how many if you want to if you want to
count the number of basis vectors
because we only have to know what they
are to figure out the rank we just have
to know the number they are well you say
well for every pivot column here we have
a basis vector over there so we could
just count the number of pivot columns
but the number of pivot columns is
equivalent to just a number of pivot
entries we have because every pivot
entry gets its own column so we could
say that the rank of a the rank of a is
equal to the number number of pivot
entries of pivot entries in the reduced
row echelon form of a and as you can see
very clearly that's the exact same thing
that we deduced was equivalent to the
rank of a transpose so the dimension of
the column space of a transpose or the
dimension of the row space of a so we
can now write our conclusion the rank of
a
is definitely the same thing as the rank
of a transpose